This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Americans have long expressed their political views with their wallets. In recent months, this has ramped up with boycotts and with buycotts. That's where people express support by buying a company's products. For months now, Nordstrom has been on a list of Trump-affiliated companies to boycott. This is just, it's a wonderful line, I own some of it, I fully, I'm going to just give it, I'm going to give a free commercial here, go buy it today everybody. I deleted Uber recently due to what happened at JFK Airport when it appeared that Uber
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。长期以来，美国人一直用钱包表达他们的政治观点。最近几个月，随着抵制和“赞制”的出现，这种现象有所加剧。“赞制”是指人们通过购买某家公司的产品来表达支持。几个月来，诺德斯特龙一直被列为与特朗普有关联的抵制企业名单中。这真的，这是一句很棒的话，我自己也买了一些，我完全，我只想说，我要在这里做个免费广告，大家今天都去买吧。我最近删除了优步，因为之前在肯尼迪国际机场发生的事情，当时看起来优步
was essentially trying to break the strides. Fueled the outrage and led to some people to call for a boycott of the airline. It seems like people are a little fed up and disillusioned with sort of conventional political channels where they would normally sort of conventional political channels where they would normally sort of express their political views. And so in the absence of that legitimacy, there's been sort of a rise in political consumerism. Neuropeharia is a marketing professor at Georgetown University. She studies how consumer behavior often serves psychological needs rather than economic
实际上是在试图破坏罢工。这激起了愤怒，并导致一些人呼吁抵制这家航空公司。似乎人们对传统的政治渠道有些厌倦和幻灭，而他们过去常常通过这些渠道来表达政治观点。因此，在缺乏这种合法性的情况下，政治消费主义有所兴起。尼鲁·帕哈里亚是乔治城大学的市场营销教授。她研究消费者行为如何往往服务于心理需求而非经济
needs. When we think about the way we spend money, we may think about the comfort of a nice pair of shoes or the pleasure of a great meal. But money also serves a deeper purpose. We use money to express our feelings, to project our status, to defend our values. The products we buy tell stories, stories that we tell others, stories that we tell ourselves. For a small coffee shop, people don't really think much of the political situation, but as soon as you put a large competitor in next door, say you put a Starbucks in next door,
需求。当我们思考我们花钱的方式时，我们可能会想到一双舒适的好鞋或一顿美餐带来的快乐。但金钱也有着更深层的目的。我们用金钱来表达我们的情感、彰显我们的地位、捍卫我们的价值观。我们购买的产品在讲述故事，这些故事是我们讲给别人听的，也是我们讲给自己听的。对于一家小咖啡馆，人们其实并不太在意政治局势，但一旦你在隔壁开了一个大型竞争对手，比如在隔壁开了一家星巴克，
all of a sudden it becomes a fight between the little guy and the big guy. How money can talk? This week on Hidden Brain. Neuropejaria says she first became interested in the psychological power of consumer products because of the diamond industry. The diamond engagement ring, how else could two-month salary last forever? A diamond. I studied economics as an undergraduate and one thing they tell you as an economics major is that people are rational.
突然之间，这就成了小人物与大人物之间的较量。金钱如何说话？本周的《隐藏的大脑》。尼鲁·帕哈里亚说，她最初对消费品的心理力量产生兴趣是因为钻石产业。钻石订婚戒指，还有什么能让两个月的薪水永存呢？一颗钻石。我读本科时学的是经济学，经济学专业教导你的一点是，人是理性的。
But as far as near a hotel, there was nothing particularly rational about buying a diamond. Now, you can argue that diamonds are beautiful, but there are cheaper stones that are just as pretty. So then the question is, why are people spending so much money on these shiny rocks that have no intrinsic value and you know there's effectively a perfect substitute? And then it seemed like it was all this kind of psychological stuff that people wanted to express their status, people wanted to kind of fit in with sort of the normative practices in terms of marriage.
但在尼鲁看来，买钻石并没有什么特别理性可言。现在，你可以争辩说钻石很美丽，但还有更便宜的石头也同样漂亮。所以问题来了，为什么人们要花这么多钱买这些没有内在价值、而且你知道实际上有完美替代品的闪亮石头呢？后来这似乎变成了各种心理层面的东西，人们想要彰显自己的地位，人们想要融入婚姻方面的规范做法中。
And it's just sort of dawned on me that products have all this psychological value and that's worth real money. I mean, a whole industry is based on just sort of pure kind of signaling and psychological value. And I found that to be really interesting and sort of at odds with this notion that people are rational. This idea made Neeru think about the other ways we use money as a signaling device to express our beliefs and our values?
我突然意识到，产品具有所有这些心理价值，而这是值真金白银的。我的意思是，整个行业都仅仅建立在纯粹的信号传递和心理价值之上。我发现这非常有趣，而且与“人是理性的”这一观念相悖。这个想法让尼鲁思考了我们使用金钱作为信号装置来表达我们的信仰和价值观的其他方式。
We enact our political will, usually, by voting or supporting different kinds of legislations and things like that. So it's kind of interesting when people start taking that civic actions, these kind of civic actions into the market and then start by-coding or boycautting a certain brand or a certain company in order to express their view. And you can kind of think about it in terms of what ends up being more tangible. So if we think about voting, it's sort of an abstract process, it's not very public. Whereas when you buy a product or avoid buying a product, it's very tangible. If you're someone who doesn't buy flashy jewelry, you may say, okay, I'm not one of those
我们通常通过投票或支持各种立法等方式来行使我们的政治意愿。因此，当人们开始将这种公民行动、这些公民行动带入市场，然后开始对某个品牌或某家公司进行抵制（boy-cott）或赞制（buy-cott）以表达他们的观点时，这就变得很有趣了。你可以从最终结果是否更具形之有物的角度来思考这个问题。如果我们考虑投票，这是一种抽象的过程，不是很公开。而当你购买一件产品或避免购买一件产品时，它是非常具体的。如果你是一个不买浮夸珠宝的人，你可能会说，好吧，我不是那种
people who uses money to talk. Maybe. Or maybe you just don't use diamonds to talk, you use coffee. I've studied the situations between small coffee shops and large coffee shops, and so I have a paper where we show that for a small coffee shop, if it's just sitting there by itself, people don't really think much of the political situation. They just think more about the coffee, sort of about the more rational, economic features and attributes of the product.
用金钱说话的人。也许吧。或者你只是不用钻石说话，你用咖啡。我研究过小咖啡馆和大咖啡馆之间的局势，我写过一篇论文，我们在论文中表明，对于一家小咖啡馆来说，如果它只是孤零零地呆在那里，人们其实不会太在意政治局势。他们更多地考虑咖啡本身，也就是产品更理性、更经济的特征和属性。
But as soon as you put a large competitor in next door, say you put a Starbucks in next door, all of a sudden it becomes a fight between the little guy and the big guy, and then buying your cup of coffee is really meaningful. All of a sudden it's a symbol of what you believe in. It's a symbol of you supporting the little guy, of you supporting the underdog and trying to stick it to the man. And it's so tangible, and I just find it so fascinating that that's sort of how we kind of, we kind of express our political views on a daily basis and we feel, you know, powerful in a sense that we actually sort of have a say in this situation.
但一旦你在隔壁引入了一个大型竞争对手，比如在隔壁开了一家星巴克，突然之间这就变成了小人物和大人物之间的较量，那么买一杯咖啡就变得意义非凡了。突然之间，它成了你信仰的象征。它是你支持小人物、支持弱势群体并试图对抗强权的象征。它是如此具体，我只是觉得这太迷人了，这就是我们日常表达政治观点的方式，我们感到，在某种程度上我们很有力量，我们在这种情况下实际上有发言权。
Companies, of course, pay attention to what consumers want. They understand that people don't just want to buy a cup of coffee or a computer. They want the right story to go with that cup of coffee or computer. This is why so many Silicon Valley companies that are worth billions of dollars spend so much time telling us about their origin stories, how two kids dropped out of college to explore a dream in someone's garage. So this is what we call, we have another paper around underdog brand biographies and this sort of idea of kind of starting in a garage from humble beginnings, but overcoming obstacles to kind of fulfill your dream.
公司当然会关注消费者的需求。他们明白，人们不仅仅想买一杯咖啡或一台电脑。他们希望那杯咖啡或那台电脑能配上一个合适的故事。这就是为什么许多价值数十亿美元的硅谷公司花那么多时间给我们讲述他们的起源故事，比如两个孩子如何辍学并在某人的车库里探索梦想。所以这就是我们所谓的，我们还有另一篇关于弱者品牌传记的论文，这种从车库里卑微起步，但克服障碍来实现梦想的想法。
That's a really compelling narrative, especially to Americans. I think because of the whole kind of pull yourself up from your bootstraps and this whole notion of the American dream. And so companies that take advantage of that narrative, and if they use it effectively, even as they grow, can kind of remind consumers that this was a small company and they might identify with it more and less penalize them less for being a large company. There tends to be sort of a kind of an aversion or a disdain for large companies.
这是一个非常引人入胜的故事，对美国人来说尤其如此。我认为这是因为那种“靠自己的靴带振作起来”的整体精神以及美国梦的整个概念。因此，利用这种叙事的公司，如果他们能有效地利用它，即使在他们成长之后，也能提醒消费者这曾是一家小公司，消费者可能会对它更有认同感，从而不那么因为它们是大公司而对它们进行惩罚。人们往往对大公司有一种厌恶或轻蔑的情绪。
People tend to identify a lot more with smaller companies. And you tell the story of Nantucket Nectars, which also has the same sort of start-up story? A lot of companies, they talk about how Nantucket Nectars in particular talks about how they started with a blender and a dream, and Cliffbar talks about how they started in their garage with, he was living with his dog and his skis and you know, was cooking and it's a sort of underdog narrative that makes use of the sort of external disadvantage but really trying hard and I think people really find that story resonating because I think we all on some level feel like underdogs and so it sort of is can be motivating to us. Companies are also extremely skilled at selling us things that are tied to a certain
人们往往对小公司有更多的认同感。你讲了Nantucket Nectars的故事，它也有类似的发家故事吗？很多公司，他们谈到Nantucket Nectars特别谈到他们是如何从一个搅拌机和一个梦想开始的，Cliffbar谈到他们是如何在车库里开始的，当时他和他的狗还有滑雪板住在一起，你知道，在做饭，这是一种弱者叙事，利用了外部劣势但真的很努力，我认为人们真的发现这个故事很有共鸣，因为我认为我们在某种程度上都觉得自己是弱者，所以这在某种程度上可以激励我们。公司也非常擅长向我们销售与某种
sense of identity. I remember this set of ads that Apple was running some years ago where they basically suggested that people who bought Macs were hyper and cooler than people who bought PCs. Hello, I'm Mac. And I'm a PC. I'm a free to ask. Well, I was sitting on my desk. Yeah. Someone walked by,
身份认同感相关联的东西。我记得苹果公司几年前播放过的一系列广告，它们基本上暗示买Mac的人比买PC的人更有活力、更酷。嗨，我是Mac。而我是一台PC。我是一台自由请求。好吧，我正坐在我的桌子上。是的。有人走过，
carelessly tripped over my power cord, yanked me straight down to the ground. Bam! Yikes! Mac would come with this power cord that connects magnetically, so when it gets pulled, it just pops right off. Everything's just kind of thought out. You know, like the tiny built-in ice I carry.
不小心绊到了我的电源线，把我直接拽到了地上。砰！哎呀！Mac带有一种磁吸电源线，所以当它被拉扯时，它就会直接弹开。一切都考虑得很周到。你知道，就像我随身携带的微型内置冰块。
My life is flashing before my eyes. I see a sunset in a field of beautiful wheat. Isn't that your screensaver? Yeah. They were basically saying, if you buy this kind of computer, it sends a signal of the kind of person you are. It's not so much about your status, but how cool you are. Yeah, and I think being cool is also a form of status. There's actually recent research on this by Warren and Campbell, and they talk about
我的人生在眼前闪现。我看到一片美丽的麦田里的日落。那不是你的屏保吗？是的。它们基本上是在说，如果你买这种电脑，它会发出一个信号，表明你是哪种人。这与其说是关于你的地位，不如说是关于你有多酷。是的，而且我认为酷也是一种地位的形式。沃伦和坎贝尔最近对此进行了研究，他们谈到
how coolness is essentially another way of kind of signaling your status, which can be very compelling to certain groups of consumers. You want to signal their autonomy, that they're not just drones and just kind of following the masses, but that they're autonomous, that they have control and are kind of independently minded. There is some irony here in an advertising campaign by a major company trying to convince people that if you buy products made by that company,
酷本质上是标榜你地位的另一种方式，这对某些消费者群体来说非常有吸引力。你想标榜他们的自主性，他们不仅仅是无人机，不仅是盲目跟风，而是他们是自主的，他们有控制权，并且具有独立思维。这里面具有一定的讽刺意味，一家大公司通过广告活动试图说服人们，如果你购买该公司制造的产品，
you're actually acting independently and autonomously. When in fact the advertising is actually making you do what the company wants you to do. Yeah, it is interesting. I mean, I remember in high school that there was a whole group of kids who would wear Metallica shirts and they were trying to show how different they were, but yet they were all wearing Metallica shirts and so they were sort of, it was sort of defeated the purpose on some level, but it wasn't immediately apparent to them. One thing that Neurohose found is that consumers are attracted not just to high-end brands,
你实际上是在独立自主地行动。而事实上，广告却在促使你去做公司想让你做的事。是的，这很有趣。我的意思是，我记得在高中时，有一群孩子穿着Metallica的T恤，他们试图展示自己有多么不同，但他们都穿着Metallica的T恤，所以在某种程度上这违背了初衷，但这并没有立即被他们察觉。尼鲁发现的一件事是，消费者不仅被高端品牌吸引，
but to powerful brands. Walmart can be a status symbol. Yeah, it's kind of interesting. So there's this relationship between status and power. And so status is a way, it's sort of what we get when we have power. And so when we think about power, we can think about Walmart as being a really powerful brand. It has a lot of strength in the marketplace. And so that strength, that kind of access to power, having a lot of resources as a brand in itself, even though it's kind of a low-end brand, if you compare it to other low-end brands, that can be kind of attractive to people who care about status.
而且被强大的品牌吸引。沃尔玛可以成为一种地位的象征。是的，这挺有趣的。所以地位和力量之间存在着这种关系。因此，地位是一种方式，是我们拥有力量时所获得的东西。所以当我们思考力量时，我们可以认为沃尔玛是一个非常强大的品牌。它在市场上有很大的影响力。因此，这种影响力，这种获得力量的途径，作为一个品牌本身就拥有大量资源，尽管它是一种低端品牌，如果你把它和其他低端品牌相比，这对关心地位的人来说可能很有吸引力。
When we come back, I'm going to speak to Nero about how we use money not just to express our values, but to ignore them. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Many of us understand the economic choices we make and have real ethical consequences. The products we buy can adversely affect the environment or take advantage of poor people in distant countries. We can buy stuff from stores that treat their employees well, or we can buy things sometimes
当我们回来时，我将与尼鲁讨论我们如何不仅用金钱来表达我们的价值观，还用金钱来忽视它们。请留作收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们许多人都明白我们做出的经济选择会带来真实的道德后果。我们购买的产品可能会对环境产生负面影响，或者剥削遥远国家穷人。我们可以从善待员工的商店买东西，或者有时从
at a cheaper price from stores that treat their employees poorly. Often after a big new story about conditions at sweatshops or the use of child labor, this public outrage. But as Nero Paharia has explored, our actions don't always match our rhetoric. She wants to throw the paper on the subject title, sweatshop labor is wrong unless the shoes are cute. The idea there is that you kind of decide how much you like something and so you really like a pair of shoes.
善待员工不佳的商店以更便宜的价格买东西。通常，在关于血汗工厂环境或使用童工的大新闻报道之后，会出现公众的愤怒。但正如尼鲁·帕哈里亚所探讨的那样，我们的行动并不总是与我们的言辞相符。她想把这篇题为《血汗工厂的劳工是错误的，除非鞋子很可爱》的论文公之于众。这个想法是，你先决定你有多喜欢某样东西，然后你真的很喜欢一双鞋。
And so then kind of the moral reasoning starts from there. It doesn't start from kind of a neutral place where you're like, where you say, oh, a sweatshirt labor is wrong. You know, under any circumstances, I don't want to subject people to these unfortunate working conditions. It actually starts at a place where you're like, well, the product's really nice. And the shoes look really good on me.
然后道德推理就从那里开始了。它不是从一个中立的地方开始的，比如你说，哦，血汗工厂的劳工是错误的。你知道，在任何情况下，我都不会让人们遭受这些不幸的工作条件。它实际上从一个这样的地方开始：嗯，这个产品真的很不错。这双鞋穿在我脚上很好看。
And then you start reasoning about it. And that's called motivated reasoning. So rather than think about morality in terms of this kind of objective thing, we kind of think about it more like a lawyer. So we decide what we want. And then we kind of come up with the reasons to support it. So we may say, oh, if we see a pair of shoes that we don't like, we may say, oh, switch up labor is wrong.
然后你开始为此进行推理。这被称为动机性推理。因此，我们不是用这种客观的眼光来看待道德，而是更像一个律师那样思考。所以我们决定我们想要什么。然后我们想出各种理由来支持它。所以我们可能会说，哦，如果我们看到一双我们不喜欢鞋子，我们可能会说，哦，血汗工厂的劳工是错误的。
I don't like switch up labor. I don't approve. But if the shoes are cute, you might say something like, oh, it's OK, because people need jobs. Your companies need to make money. So you'll be more likely to agree with these things because you're motivated. In a sense, the shoes are really cute.
我不喜欢血汗工厂的劳工。我不赞同。但如果鞋子很可爱，你可能会说这样的话：哦，这没关系，因为人们需要工作。你的公司需要赚钱。所以你更有可能同意这些事情，因为你有动机。从某种意义上说，鞋子真的很可爱。
You really want them. And so you want to find a way to kind of reconcile your kind of distaste for this situation and the kind of the reality of it. And you've actually conducted experiments which show that people are more likely to reach for these kinds of rationalizations when they actually like a product. Yes, exactly. So if they like a product, if you show them sort of an attractive pair of shoes, they'll be more likely to agree with these economic justifications. If you show them an unattractive pair of shoes, all of a sudden they become these kind
你真的很想要它们。所以你想找到一种方法来调和你的这种厌恶情绪与这种情况的现实。而你实际上已经进行了实验，表明当人们真正喜欢某种产品时，他们更有可能使用这类合理化解释。是的，完全正确。因此，如果他们喜欢某款产品，如果你向他们展示一双很有吸引力的鞋子，他们就会更有可能赞同这些经济上的合理化借口。如果你向他们展示一双毫无吸引力的鞋子，突然之间他们就变成了那种富有道德感的动物，他们会说，哦不，这是错误的。所以这个想法是，我们只是根据我们对某样东西的渴望程度来决定什么是道德的。你所关注的一点是，只要我们能找到一种方法将自己与产生它的不道德行为保持距离，我们往往愿意顺从那些在道德上有问题的产品。我们与不道德行为或不道德行动之间的距离越远，执行起来就越容易。
of moral animals who say, oh no, it's wrong. And so the idea is that we just decide what is moral based on, you know, how much we want something. What one thing you've looked at is that we're often willing to go along with products that are ethically problematic so long as we can come up with a way to distance ourselves from the unethical behavior that produced it. The more distance we can put between ourselves and the unethical behavior or the unethical action, the easier it becomes to perform.
这符合这样一个观点：如果我走到杂货店要求一只鸡，他们出去为我杀了一只鸡，比起我只是从托盘里拿一只鸡，我对这件事的感觉会更糟糕。当然，在两种情况下，都必须有一只鸡被杀。但在一种情况下，我觉得我实际上要求杀死这只鸡。在另一种情况下，脏活已经做完了。
This goes to the idea that if I went to the grocery store and asked for a chicken and they went out and killed a chicken for me, I would feel worse about that than if I was just picking up the chicken from a tray. And of course, in both cases, a chicken had to be killed. But in one case, I feel like I have actually asked for the chicken to be killed. In the other case, the dirty walk has already been done. Yeah. So there's a number of things that sort of enable us to not feel so close to the harm. I mean, essentially, you're buying a product from a company, but what you're doing is you're hiring them to do kind of this dirty work for you. So say any clothing company, they're the ones
是的。因此，有很多事情使我们能够不那么深切地感受到这种伤害。我的意思是，本质上，你是在向一家公司购买产品，但你所做的是你雇佣他们为你做这种脏话。比如任何服装公司，他们才是
who hire, you know, a child and maybe, child and maybe under some unfortunate conditions. You're not directly actually hiring that person. But I think the second thing that happens is this idea of the order of how kind of supply and demand happens. So we live in an economy where most items are produced first. And so they're already produced. They're already in the store. And so when you go to the
雇佣童工的人，也许是在一些不幸的条件下。你并没有直接雇佣那个人。但我认为发生的第二件事是关于供求关系发生顺序的想法。所以我们生活在一个大多数物品都是首先生产出来的经济体中。所以它们已经被生产出来了。它们已经在商店里了。所以当你去
store, the damage has been done, so to speak. So it's already been done, it's already happened, but imagine that you went into that same store and you had to order your chicken or your clothes on demand. So if you order it on demand, you know, they then they will put a child, you know, have them work under these unfortunate conditions and then you start feeling responsible and guilty for this situation where when it's already happened, you feel like, oh, well, it's already happened and I'm not responsible for it. And I think people don't really kind of see this broader role that consumers have in creating demand for these kinds of products. They don't see that A causes B because it sort of happens backwards,
商店时，可以说损害已经造成了。所以它已经完成了，已经发生了，但想象一下你走进同一家商店，你必须按需定制你的鸡肉或衣服。如果你按需定制，你知道，他们就会安排一个孩子，让他们在这些不幸的条件下工作，然后你开始对这种情况感到责任和负罪感，而当它已经发生时，你会觉得，哦，好吧，它已经发生了，我对此不负责任。我认为人们并没有真正看到消费者在为这类产品创造需求方面所扮演的更广泛角色。他们没有看到A导致B，因为它是反向发生的，
that they actually make the product first, and then you decide if you want it. But if we lived in an economy that was all on demand, then it would happen the other way. You would decide you want it, and then they would make it, and then there would be a stronger connection, kind of a stronger cause-and-effect connection, that I think people would then feel a bit more responsible and a bit more guilty for these kinds of situations. I can imagine that people would feel horrible
他们实际上先制造产品，然后你决定是否想要它。但如果我们生活在一个完全按需定制的经济体中，那么情况就会反过来。你决定你想要它，然后他们制造它，这样就会有一种更强的联系，一种更强的因果联系，我认为人们随后会对手头的这种状况感到更多的责任和负罪感。我可以想象人们会感到糟糕，
if they said I want a shirt and they have to send some poor nine-year-old kid into the basement to make the shirt for the next six hours. I mean, people would feel awful about that. Yeah, and I think people wouldn't do it it and so then it kind of gets to this question of, does the economic structure and the structure of how goods are made, does the kind of logistical structure impact how we think about ethics and how we think about our own role in enabling these kinds of harms?
如果他们说我想要一件衬衫，而他们必须把某个可怜的九岁小孩送到地下室在接下来六小时里为他们做这件衬衫。我的意思是，人们对此会感到糟糕透顶。是的，我觉人们不会那样做，这就归结到了这样一个问题：经济结构和商品的制造结构，这种物流结构是否会影响我们对道德的看法以及我们对自己在助长这些伤害中所扮演角色的看法？
The companies who make stuff for us are run by people and those people have minds in enabling these kinds of harms. The companies who make stuff for us are run by people, and those people have minds that work like our minds. So, should companies no surprise that just as consumers would rather have companies do the dirty work for them, to distance themselves from the ethical consequences of their economic actions, companies often choose to do exactly the same thing. Rather than run a factory that makes clothing
为我们制造东西的公司是由人运营的，而这些人有着像我们一样的心智来促成这些伤害。为我们制造东西的公司是由人运营的，而这些人有着像我们一样的心智运作方式。所以，正如消费者宁愿让公司为他们干脏活以使自己与经济行动的道德后果保持距离一样，公司往往也会选择做完全相同的事情，这也就不足为奇了。与其经营一家在恶劣工作条件下制造服装的工厂，
under offer working conditions, why not outsource the dirty work to someone else? If a reporter I know it's details of poor working conditions, you can now plausibly say, but I didn't know about it. In many cases, companies actually do outsource the harm, so rather than own the factory that makes the clothing under these terrible conditions, we outsource them to other firms that are owned by other entities.
为什么不把脏活外包给别人呢？如果我知道某个记者掌握了糟糕工作条件的细节，你现在就可以貌似有理地说，但我不知道这件事。在许多情况下，公司确实将伤害外包了，因此，与其拥有在这些糟糕条件下制造服装的工厂，我们不如将它们外包给由其他实体拥有的其他公司。
So a lot of these companies do try and claim that they had no knowledge of this, this did not happen within the boundaries of my firm. It turns out that both individuals and companies often prefer to be kept in the dark about unethical practices that are further up the supply chain. So there was a really, really interesting paper by Julie Irwin and some other colleagues who wrote a paper on this idea of willful ignorance. And the idea was that you had a product and you had access to a whole bunch of different pieces of information. And one of them was the labor conditions or the environmental conditions.
因此，许多这类公司确实试图声称他们对此一无所知，这并没有发生在我的公司的范围内。事实证明，个人和公司往往都宁愿对供应链上游的不道德做法保持无知。朱莉·欧文（Julie Irwin）和其他一些同事写了一篇关于这种“故意无知”概念的论文，非常非常有趣。这个想法是，你拥有一个产品，并且你可以获得大量不同的信息。其中之一就是劳动条件或环境条件。
And the question was, do people actually ask for this information? You can look at it if you want, but you could decide not to look at it. And it turns out people didn't want to look at that information because they didn't really want to be confronted with this kind of conflict between their beliefs and what they really wanted. And they found this effect was stronger for people who cared more about labor issues, who cared more about environmental issues. They were more likely to avoid this information in order to kind of avoid this conflict. Think of the deep irony of what Nero just said.
问题是，人们真的会索取这些信息吗？如果你想的话你可以看，但你可以决定不看。事实证明，人们不想看这些信息，因为他们真的不想面对这种信念与他们真正想要的之间的冲突。他们发现，对于那些更关心劳工问题、更关心环境问题的人来说，这种效应更强。他们更有可能回避这些信息，以避免这种冲突。想想尼鲁刚才所说的话所蕴含的深刻讽刺。
The folks who care the most about ethics might be most willing to turn a blind eye to unethical business practices because they know if they found out about those practices, they would feel obliged to do something about it. We've talked about the many ways in which consumers and companies play games with one another using products to speak on their behalf or using products behind which they can hide. But there's one dimension of economic activity we haven't explored, and that's time. I asked Nero how some of us use our calendars to broadcast our social status. It used to be that people want broadcast their social status by being idle.
最关心道德的人可能最愿意对不道德的商业行为视而不见，因为他们知道如果他们发现了这些做法，他们就会觉得有义务采取行动。我们已经讨论了消费者和公司利用产品相互博弈的多种方式，要么用产品代表自己发言，要么将自己藏在产品背后。但经济活动中还有一个我们尚未探讨的维度，那就是时间。我问尼鲁我们中的一些人如何利用日程表来广播他们的社会地位。过去，人们希望通过无所事事来广播他们的社会地位。
But that idea has been turned on its head in the United States. It turns out nowadays that people who are busier actually seem to have more social status. So rather than somebody who is very wealthy, who could waste their time, take fancy vacations, invest in learning these kind of archaic mannerisms. It turns out the person who works really hard, who's really busy, who's very effortful, is the one who's seen to have more social status. And I think in part, that is because we live
但在美国，这个观念已经被颠覆了。事实证明，如今那些更忙碌的人似乎拥有更高的社会地位。因此，与那些非常富有、可以浪费时间、进行豪华度假、投资学习这些陈旧礼仪的人相比，那些工作非常努力、非常忙碌、付出很多努力的人，才被认为拥有更高的社会地位。我认为部分原因在于我们生活在一个重视社会流动的社会中。
in a society that values social mobility. So we actually conducted the study in the US and we conducted the same study in Italy and we found that for Italian people they thought the person who was living a life of leisure had more status. Of course they have so much money they can just relax all the time. Whereas in the US they thought the person who was working all the time actually had more status and I think what was going on was that in the time actually had more status. And I think what was going on was that in the US people sort of value this sense of earned status. So status can be earned in the US where I think in Italy it's more of a society where status is inherited.
所以我们实际上在美国进行了这项研究，我们在意大利也进行了相同的研究，我们发现对意大利人来说，他们认为过着闲暇生活的人拥有更高的地位。当然，他们有那么多钱，可以一直放松。而在美国，他们认为一直在工作的人实际上拥有更高的地位，我认为原因在于在美国人们倾向于重视这种通过努力获得的地位。因此在美国地位是可以获得的，而在意大利我认为这是一个地位世袭的社会。
So for example, my co-author is Italian and she's always talking about how people come from good families or not. And so there's very much this idea that your status isn't necessarily something that you earn but you inherit. And so in that sense, working hard really wouldn't get you anywhere, whereas in America you have this sense that you can actually climb the ladder. And so celebrities, for example, might say instead of saying, you know, I make one movie every year and I get to hang out on the beach for the other 10 months of the year. They actually are suggesting, oh my god, I'm so overworked. Yeah, so we actually looked at tweets of celebrities who were tagged with this hashtag Humble
例如，我的合著者是意大利人，她总是谈论人们是否出身名门。因此，这里非常强烈地有一种观念，即你的地位不一定是你赢得的，而是你继承的。从这个意义上说，努力工作并不能让你去到任何地方，而在美国，你有一种感觉，你实际上可以往上爬。因此，例如，名人可能会说，而不是说，你知道，我每年拍一部电影，其余10个月我都可以去海滩闲逛。他们实际上是在暗示，哦天哪，我太忙了。是的，所以我们实际上查看了被贴上这个“谦虚的自吹”（HumbleBragg）标签的名人的推文，这种想法是吹嘘，但将其伪装成抱怨。我们发现的许多推文都与忙碌有关。所以，你知道，我今天早上必须去录音室，然后下午有一个图书会议，然后我晚上必须去纽约，加上标签“我没有生活”，你知道，诸如此类的推文。你试图表达关于你自己的某种看法。你很忙，你真的很重要。你没有时间做别的事情。所以，你会在社交媒体上看到这是一种被接受且有效的炫耀地位的方式，那就是告诉别人你有多忙。尼鲁，我想问问你自己的生活，据我了解，在你成长过程中，
Bragg, this idea of bragging, but sort of disguising it as a complaint. And a lot of the tweets we found had to do with being busy. So, you know, I have to be in the recording studio this morning and then I have a book And a lot of the tweets we found had to do with being busy. So, you know, I have to be in the recording studio this morning, and then I have a book meeting in the afternoon, and then I have to travel to New York and the evening, and Hashtag I have no life, you know, these kinds of tweets. You're trying to say something about yourself. You're busy, you're really important. You don't have time to do other things. And so, you see that on social media that's kind of an acceptable and effective way to show your status by telling people how busy you are. Newer I want to ask about your own life, which is I understand that growing up, you came
你来自这样一个家庭：在某些方面，他们不以展示对地位的执着为荣，实际上是以不买昂贵的东西来炫耀为荣。所以我具有东印度血统，我的父母移民到了这个国家，事实证明，在东印度社群中，展示你的社会地位是一件非常非常重要的事情。因此，人们真的非常有动力去展示他们的地位。当我长大的时候，那是通过买非常贵的车来实现的。所以我的很多父母的朋友，他们有捷豹，他们有奔驰。
from a family that in some ways prized not demonstrating its commitment to status, that actually prized not buying the expensive things as a way to show off. So I'm of East Indian origin and my parents immigrated to this country and it turns out in East Indian communities showing your social status is a very, very important thing. So people are really, really motivated to show their status. And when I was growing up, that was happening through buying really expensive cars. So a lot of my parents' friends, they had jaguires, and they had Mercedes.
我记得我有一次去一个朋友家，他们有一辆捷豹。她也是印度人。我问她，她当时在抱怨她妈妈在各种事情上都很节俭。我说，哦，这太奇怪了，因为你知道，她很节俭，然而你们却有一辆捷豹。她说，哦，好吧，那只是为了显摆。我只是，那一刻的坦诚真的，真的，在我的脑海中点燃了某种东西，哇，人们只是在试图显摆，我的妈妈也经常抱怨她的所有朋友如何购买这些昂贵的车，他们这样做的唯一原因就是为了显摆。
And I remember I went to a friend's house one time, and they had a jaguire. She was also Indian. And I asked her, she was complaining about her mom kind of being frugal about different things. And I said, oh, that's so strange because, you know, she's frugal and yet you have a jaguar. And she said, oh, well, that's just to show off. And I just, the candidness of that moment really, really, you know, sparked something in my mind, like, wow, people are just trying to show off in my, my mom also would often complain about how all her friends would buy these expensive cars and the only reason they were doing it was to show off.
因此我只是，我开始对这种展示社会地位的想法着迷了。我认为现在事物如何转向的一个证据，也许是转向像忙碌这样的事情，现在她所有的朋友都退休了，他们都在吹嘘自己有多忙。现在我妈妈抱怨每个人都在不停地谈论自己有多忙。所以我认为这是一种不断演变的发展机制。哈哈。
And so I just, I kind of got really fascinated with this idea of showing your social status. And I think kind of an evidence of how things are shifting now towards, maybe towards something like busyness, now all her friends are retired, and they all brag about how busy they are. And now my mom complains about everyone talks about how busy they are all the time. So I think it's sort of an evolving, kind of an evolving mechanism. Ha ha ha.
尼鲁·帕哈里亚是乔治城大学的市场营销教授。尼鲁，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。本周的节目由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Pennman）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和蕾妮·克拉克（Renee Clark）。特别鸣谢我们出色的冬季实习生克洛伊·康纳利（Chloe Connolly），
Niro Baharia is a marketing professor at Georgetown University. Niro, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. This week's episode was produced by Maggie Pennman, and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, and Renee Clark. A special shout out to our amazing winter intern, Chloe Connolly,
她本周将开启新的冒险。祝你好运，克洛伊，我们会想念你的。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们。你每周还可以在当地公共广播电台收听我的故事。我们本周的无名英雄是史蒂夫·因斯基普（Steve Inskeep）。他是《早间版》（Morning Edition）的主持人，他在电台开发《隐藏的大脑》的过程中发挥了至关重要的作用。
who's off to new adventures this week. Best of luck, Chloe, we're gonna miss you. For more Hidden Brain, follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram. You can also listen for my stories each week on your local public radio station. Our unsung hero this week is Steve Inskeep. He's the host of Morning Edition and he played a vital role in developing Hidden Brain on the radio.
他喜欢学习新事物，并且以一种具有感染力的热情对待每一个故事。香卡，我很荣幸你愿意抽出一点你极其宝贵的宝贵时间。我几乎没有时间对你说谢谢。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。
He loves learning new things and he approaches every story with an enthusiasm that's infectious. Shankar, I'm so honored that you were willing to take a little bit of your very precious time. I barely have time to say thanks to you. I'm Shankar Vedatam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
此剧集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。